Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Let the consequences be what they may, whether the Potomac is crimsoned in human gore and Pennsylvania Avenue is paved ten fathoms deep with mangled bodies, or whether the last vestige of liberty is swept from the face of the American continent, the South will never submit to such humiliation and degradation as the inauguration of abraham lincoln that's just chilling with my chilling that superb
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。无论后果如何，无论是波托马克河被鲜血染红，宾夕法尼亚大道铺满十英寻深的残缺尸体，还是美洲大陆上自由的最后痕迹被一扫而空，南方也绝不会屈服于亚伯拉罕·林肯就职那样奇耻大辱与尊严扫地，这听起来真是让人不寒而栗，这太棒了
american accent i mean i didn't even try and do an atlanta accent there but because that was that was written have you been to georgia i'll come to that in a minute that was that was from the atlanta newspaper the southern confederacy in august 1860 um i have been to savannah oh that's very georgia yeah so yes i have but you clearly didn't pick up the local dialect no i didn't i'm afraid um so many apologies to um all americans from the south who may be listening to this um i put my hands up i can't do it i really apologize um but it's we wanted to read that because i mean it is a i mean it's a kind of the death knell for the uh the peace that it held and the sense of kind of the carnage that is to come. And it's a perfect introduction to part two
美式口音，我的意思是，我甚至都没有尝试去模仿亚特兰大口音，但因为那是——那是写下来的。你去过佐治亚州吗？我一会儿会谈到这个。那是——那是1860年8月亚特兰大报纸《南方邦联》上的内容。嗯，我去过萨凡纳。哦，那是很具有佐治亚风情的地方，对吧？所以，是的，我去过，但你显然没有学到当地的方言。不，我没有，恐怕是的。所以，向所有可能在收听这期节目的南方美国人深表歉意。我举手投降，我学不来，我真的非常抱歉。但是，我们之所以想读这段话，是因为——我的意思是，它有一种——它算是一种宣告，宣告了原本维系的和平走向破灭，也预示了即将到来的血腥杀戮。这是对第二部分的完美引言
of the episode we're doing here on The Rest of History on the American Civil War. And in the first part, Adam Smith, great scholar of the period, took us through the causes of the war. And Adam, you took us up to the firing on Fort Sumter and the establishment of the Confederacy with its capital at Richmond. At what point
即我们今天在《历史的余烬》中探讨的关于美国内战的节目。在第一部分中，该时期的杰出学者亚当·斯密带我们了解了战争的起因。亚当，你为我们讲述到了萨姆特堡遭到炮击以及以里士满为首都的邦联的建立。你认为在哪个时间点
do you think it becomes absolutely clear that there is no way back? Is it the firing on Fort Sumter? That's what's traditionally said, isn't it? Or even after that, might it have been possible to pull back the dogs of war? No, I don't don't think so because by that point the this new confederacy had um this huge burst of self-confidence you know they they pulled it off they pulled off what seemed to be what may seem to us to be the most extraordinary thing to create a a new slave holding republic in the middle of the 19th century, but they'd done it. And what were the chances that the United States, with virtually no standing army, and what army it had, was kind of strung out, policing the frontier, Native Americans?
绝对可以确定已经没有退路了？是萨姆特堡遭炮击的时候吗？传统上是这么说的，对吧？还是说，即使在那之后，把战争的恶魔重新拴回笼子里仍然是有可能的？不，我不这么认为，因为到那个时候，这个新建立的邦联有了一种——这种极其膨胀的自信，你知道的，他们成功了，他们成功做成了一件在我们看来可能是最不可思议的事情——在19世纪中期建立了一个全新的蓄奴共和国，但他们真的做到了。而且，几乎没有常备军、仅有的一点军队还分散在边境地区维持治安、对抗美洲原住民的合众国，
What chance had they got of subduing militarily an area that's the size of Western Europe? How were they going to manage that? Do they think that there simply won't be a war that people in the north will just accept it i think there's definitely many southerners who hope that because they have a pretty low opinion but do they think it i think some of them who thought it yeah some of them calculated that the north was too divided um that it was made up of this polyglot. We didn't talk in the last episode about immigration,
他们有什么胜算在军事上征服一个面积相当于西欧的地区？他们打算怎么应付？他们以为战争根本不会爆发，北方人会全盘接受吗？我认为肯定有很多南方人是这么希望的，因为他们对北方的看法相当低。但他们真的这么认为吗？我认为他们当中确实有人是这么想的，对吧？他们中的一些人盘算着北方太过分裂，由各种混杂的群体组成。我们在上一期节目中没有谈到移民，
but that's actually part of the story here, this big-scale immigration of Catholic Irish mainly into New York and Boston and Philadelphia in the 1850s. And Southerners look at this, and the Germans come in as well, and the Southerners look at this and the germans come in as well and the the southerners look at this and they think you know this this polyglot conglomeration of greasy mechanics you know they don't know how to handle a gun they've got they've got no clue they've got no capacity there's no political will so they're not going to be able to fight us and but if there is a war there'll be one great climactic napoleonic style battle and clearly we'll win it and it'll be job done.
但这其实也是这个故事的一部分，也就是1850年代，天主教爱尔兰人（主要是）大规模移民到纽约、波士顿和费城。南方人看到这一点，德国人也涌入了，南方人看到这一点，德国人也涌入了，南方人看到这一点，然后他们心想，你知道的，这群由油腻腻的机械工组成的混杂大杂烩，你知道的，他们根本不知道怎么拿枪，他们一窍不通，毫无能力，也没有政治意愿，所以他们根本没法跟我们打仗；但就算真的爆发了战争，也只会有一场决定性的拿破仑式的大决战，而我们显然会赢，到时候就大功告成了。
But Adam, I mean, the question that always has been on my mind is why, and I mean, a lot of Americans will say, oh, it's obvious, but I would say to an outsider, to a non-American, it's not obvious. The northerners hate slavery. They think slavery is corrupting. They think the South is sunk in sin, is steeped in sin sin why don't the northerners just let the south go i mean why don't they just say okay sod you set up your tin pot confederacy we've got you know billions more factories than you we're much more prosperous we're much more productive we're not corrupted by slavery you'll sink like a stone and then you'll
但是，亚当，我的意思是，我心里一直有一个疑问，那就是为什么——我的意思是，很多美国人会说，哦，这显而易见；但我要对一个外行、一个非美国人说，这其实并不显眼。北方人痛恨奴隶制。他们认为奴隶制正在腐蚀人心。他们认为南方深陷罪恶、被罪恶浸透——为什么北方人不干脆放南方走呢？我的意思是，为什么他们不直接说：“好吧，随你的便，去建立你们那个不入流的小邦联吧。我们有比你们多得多的工厂，我们繁荣得多，生产力高得多，我们没有受到奴隶制的腐蚀，你们会像石头一样沉下去，然后你们
come begging to us in 10 years please can, can we come back into the union? I mean, why don't they do that? Yeah. I mean, it's a question I've been asking for 20 years, actually, Dominic. I mean, I think you're absolutely right. It is the question. Because I think the other side of it, which is not hard for me to explain why Southerners wanted to secede. There's a lot much more being written about that question.
会在十年后跑来求我们：‘求求你们，我们能重回联邦吗？’”我的意思是，他们为什么不这么做呢？是的。我的意思是，多米尼克，这也是我20年一直在问的问题。我的意思是，我觉得你完全说对了。这确实是个核心问题。因为我觉得问题的另一面——解释南方人为什么要分裂并不难理解。关于这个问题已经有很多文章了。
And to me, it's not really a mystery at all i think they're absolutely given their own given the situation they were in by 1860 i think they were quite right to roll the dice and the southerners the southerners yeah it's like i mean it it turned out really really badly for them but i think i can totally see why given the election of lincoln they were going to be they were going to be a lot more republican presidents potentially where he came from given the shifting shifting demographics, given the electoral system. And it's really hard to maintain an oppressive system of human enslavement. You've got to know that the polity that you are existing in respects and is going to uphold the idea of property in human beings. And if you've got a president of your country who doesn't believe that property in human beings is legitimate, that's really, really bad.
在我看来，这其实根本不是什么谜团。我认为，鉴于他们到1860年所处的局势，他们放手一搏完全是正确的——南方人，南方人，是的。这就像是——我的意思是，结果对他们来说非常非常糟糕，但我完全能理解，考虑到林肯的当选，未来可能会有更多共和党总统，考虑到他当时的立场、人口结构的变化以及选举制度。要维持一个压迫人类的奴隶制体系是非常困难的。你必须确信你所处政治共同体尊重并会坚定维护对人类的私有产权这一理念。而如果你的国家出现了一位不认为拥有人类奴隶是合法财产的总统，那情况可就真的、真的太糟糕了。
So, you know, it makes it make complete sense. Now, there are lots of reasons why. But yeah, but hang on. The enslaved people can still escape across the north and then you won't have the Fugitive Slave Act to get your property as you think of it returned. But then they're saying well that wasn't working anyway so what have you lost really so it makes complete sense why southerners wanted to secede but your question why then did northerners respond to secession with a war to save the union is a right one after all i mean what would we do if uh when scotland votes for independence are you
所以，你知道的，这完全说得通。现在，原因有很多。但是，等等。被奴役的人仍然可以逃往北方，那样的话，你就没有《逃亡奴隶法》来把你的“财产”（如你所认为的）追回来了。但他们会说，反正那条法律也没起作用，所以你到底失去了什么呢？因此，南方人想要分裂是完全合乎情理的。但你的问题是：为什么北方人后来会对分裂做出反应，并进行一场为了拯救联邦的战争？这是一个正确的问题。毕竟，如果——呃，苏格兰投票独立，我们会怎么做？你
gonna join up to fight for the union perhaps you will tom i don't know i think you've written quite passionately on this. Tom has got, I mean, I've been to Tom's house. He's got a whole room full of stuff, like ready to go. He's got like disguisery. Yeah, he's got it all. Well, actually, we've got a house on the north bank of the Tweed, just inside Scotland.
会加入军队为联邦而战吗？也许你会的，汤姆，我不知道。我觉得你在这方面写过相当充满激情的文章。汤姆有——我的意思是，我去过汤姆的家。他有一整间屋子都是这类的东西，随时准备开战。他甚至有伪装服。是的，他什么都有。好吧，实际上，我们在特威德河北岸有一座房子，刚好在苏格兰境内。
So it'll be a bridgehead. Fort Sumter. But yeah, I mean, obviously there's your example Adam right I mean okay so but anyway I've not answered your question here let me try and answer your question why why did I mean the word I mean suppose some people did say that let the southern let the erring sisters depart in peace it was a headline in the New York Tribune I mean there was that there was that sentiment but why not because in the end the point is this the united states is the last best hope of earth that's abraham lincoln's phrase it is and that and just think about that this is the last refuge for for humanity if the experiment in democracy of constitutional government is seen to fail, if the response to a duly constituted election is that half of the country
所以那将会是一个桥头堡。萨姆特堡。不过，说真的，显然这就是你的例子，亚当，对吧？我的意思是，好吧——但无论如何，我还没回答你的问题。让我试着回答你的问题：为什么——我的意思是，有些人确实说过，让南方的“迷途姐妹”和平离去吧。《纽约论坛报》上曾有过这样的头条。我的意思是，确实有过这种情绪。但为什么不这样做呢？因为归根结底，关键在于：合众国是地球上最后、最好的希望。那是亚特兰大·林肯的名言——是亚伯拉罕·林肯的名言。而且，想想看，这是全人类最后的避难所。如果民主制度和宪政政府的试验被证明失败了，如果对一场合法进行的选举的回应是国家的一半，
or almost half of the country throws its toys out of the pram and walks out, then the light of freedom will dim around the world but also a house divided against itself cannot stand so so if half the house goes and there's the rest the whole house may collapse so that's lincoln lincoln made that speech shouldn't he i think in the lincoln douglas debates that a house divided itself can't stand that's right isn't it but i mean 1858 why don't if the house so patently is divided why not just cut off the stand that's right isn't it but i mean 1858 why did if the house so patently is divided why not just cut off the bit that's the problem the rotten bits as it were and the rest of your house is going to be fine i mean that would be my argument in some ways if you're a northerner
或者近一半的国家像小孩子发脾气一样把玩具一扔、拂袖而去，那么全世界的自由之光都会黯淡。而且，一个自相分裂的房子是站立不住的。所以，如果半个房子倒塌了，其余的部分——整个房子都可能会崩溃。所以那是林肯，林肯发表过那个演讲，不是吗？我记得是在林肯-道格拉斯辩论中说过，一个自相分裂的房子是站立不住的，对吧？但是，我的意思是，在1858年，如果这个房子如此显而易见地分裂了，为什么不直接把那个有问题的地方切断呢？——正如你所说，就是那些烂掉的部分，这样你房子的其余部分就能安然无恙了。我的意思是，从某种程度上讲，如果你是一个北方人，这就会是我的论点。
you might well say listen we're a lot better off without those clowns they're bad people they've got slaves you know they're backward because that's what a lot of northerners thought about the south right they thought they were backward and kind of fly bitten and and all this sort of stuff um i mean i would say it still is quite baffling that you're prepared to lose you know lose what is it more than 300 000 northerners die in the civil war to force these people to be back in their their country yeah yeah yeah um and you you've got i mean i agree i think it is baffling it's something i've really i've been struggling with for 20 years i mean you you have american listeners they can write in and tell you why us three brits asking
你很可能会说：“听着，没有这群小丑，我们过得更好。他们是坏人，他们蓄奴，你知道的，他们很落后。”因为这就是很多北方人对南方的看法，对吧？他们认为南方落后、充满苍蝇叮咬，还有诸如此类的一切。嗯，我想说的是，你竟然准备牺牲——牺牲30万以上的北方人在内战中丧生，以强迫这些人回到你们的国家——这依然让人感到相当费解。是的，是的，嗯，你也——我的意思是，我同意，我觉得这确实很费解。这是我20年里一直在纠结的事情。我的意思是，你们有美国的听众，他们可以写信告诉你们，为什么我们三个英国人会提出
this question what what we're missing and why it's all so ludicrous that we're even asking the question but the answer must have something to do with the idea of the union yeah it must do and what that promise of the revolution and the declaration of independence represents i mean it's it's it's kind of very on brand now to to sneer at the idea that there was a kind of moral imperative behind the union in the civil war that it's couched in overtly cynical terms and yet this i i can't understand why they would have done it unless a certain sense of kind of an identification of their cause with what was best not just for the north but for the united
这个问题，我们忽略了什么，以及为什么我们甚至还在问这个问题显得如此荒谬。但这个答案肯定与联邦的理念有关。是的，肯定有关系，以及革命和《独立宣言》的承诺所代表的意义。我的意思是，现在去嘲讽内战中联邦背后存在某种道德必然性的观点，或者将其归结为公开的愤世嫉俗的论调，这在现在很符合某种“人设”；然而，我无法理解他们为什么会这么做，除非他们对自己的事业有一种认同感，认为这不仅仅对北方最好，而且对整个美国
states and for the whole of the world yes it was in play i mean it's it's yes you've put that very well that's exactly what they said repeatedly and i think that's exactly what they thought. I mean, the flip side of that was the humiliation they said they felt, how diminished they felt on the world stage as a result of secession. That this was a necessary project in order, the fiery trial through which they now had to pass was necessary in order to prove themselves as a real nation on the global stage. Adam, we've been talking about it so far as though North and South are absolutely distinguishable, or as though in effect, they have become two separate countries. But of course, we call it the American Civil War. And that implies, you know, institutions and even families
乃至全世界都是最好的，这种理念确实在发挥作用。是的，你把这一点表达得非常好。这正是他们一再强调的，我也认为这正是他们的想法。我的意思是，硬币的另一面是他们所感受到的屈辱，他们因分裂而在世界舞台上感觉得到了贬损。这是一项必要的工程，他们现在必须经历的烈火洗礼，对于在世界舞台上证明自己是一个真正的国家是必不可少的。亚当，我们之前一直在讨论，就好像北方和南方是截然不同的，或者就好像实际上它们已经成了两个不同的国家。但当然，我们称之为美国内战。这意味着，你知道的，各种机构甚至是家庭
being divided. And i suppose an obvious institution that does end up divided would be west point which is the great u.s military academy where large numbers of of graduates and officers who are commanding heights of the u.s army have to decide which which of the two sides they're going to go for um and i suppose the emblematic figure who has to make his mind up is perhaps the most famous general of all, perhaps from Ulysses S. Grant, which is the guy who ends up leading the Confederacy, Robert E. Lee. So what's his background? And how does he come to choose the Confederacy over the Union?
都被分裂了。我想，一个最终遭到分裂的显赫机构就是西点军校，它是伟大的美国军事学院，大量的毕业生和占据美洲军队核心地位的军官们不得不决定他们将效忠哪一方。我想，那个必须做出抉择的标志性人物，或许也是最著名的将军，也许来自尤利西斯·S·格兰特——抱歉，是最终领导邦联的那个人，罗伯特·E·李。那么他的背景是什么？他又是如何决定选择邦联而非联邦的？
Because he actually gets offered the leadership of the Union, doesn't he? He does, because he's regarded as one of the most able officers in the United States Army in 1860, 1861. He is a career army officer, but he's a Virginian. We mentioned him in the last episode. He was the guy who arrested John Brown when Brown launched his raid on Harper's Ferry in Virginia to trying to distribute the guns from that arsenal and set off a slave interaction. So, you know, the story about Lee that has been told down the generations and that is much cherished by, you know, has been much cherished, still is by white Southerners, is that he was in an agony of indecision. You know, what should he do? You know, he's, after all, he's an officer of the United States. So he's sworn an oath to uphold the Constitution of the United States. But in his heart, he's a Virginian, and he's completely divided on what's he going to do. In the end, he can't bring himself to lead an army of invasion into his home state that's the story that's that's told about robert e lee well i think
因为他实际上曾被提供联邦军队的指挥权，对吧？是的，因为在1860年和1861年，他被视为美国陆军中最能干的军官之一。他是一名职业军官，但他是个弗吉尼亚人。我们在上一期节目中提到过他。当约翰·布朗在弗吉尼亚州哈珀斯费里发动袭击，企图分发军火库中的武器并挑起一场奴隶起义时，正是他逮捕了约翰·布朗。所以，你知道的，世世代代流传下来、并且被白人南方人（过去和现在）倍加珍视的关于李的传奇故事是，他当时正处于极其痛苦的犹豫不决中。你知道的，他该怎么办？你知道的，毕竟他是美洲的军官。因此，他宣誓效忠并维护美洲宪法。但在他的内心深处，他是个弗吉尼亚人，对于自己该作何选择，他内心极为分裂。最终，他无法让自己去领导一支入侵家乡军队——这就是关于罗伯特·E·李的传奇故事。好吧，我认为
that that is giving i think what that undersells is the extent to which lee like other elite white virginians was fundamentally committed to slavery well because his wife owns large numbers of plantations right yeah and slaves and yes he's he's fully married into he's part of a virginia dynasty that has owned uh slaves for uh generations he cannot he temperamentally culturally intellectually politically he is he loathes everything that this new insurgent radical Republican, as people would probably call it like him, black Republican Party represents. There's just no way, no way that Robert E. Lee was ever going to be comfortable leading the union army right because it's an important part of his brand that he's so he gets compared to a perfect british gentleman by a you know british observer during the war he's a kind of silver fox he's very stylish well that's the confederacy's brand though tom i mean that really is the confederacy's brand i mean i read in my children's history book
这——我认为这淡化了另一种程度：李和其他精英白人弗吉尼亚人一样，从根本上对奴隶制深信不疑。因为他的妻子拥有大量种植园，对吧？是的，还有奴隶，是的，他完全融入了——他是弗吉尼亚门阀的一部分，世世代代都拥有奴隶。他在气质上、文化上、知识上、政治上都痛恨这个新崛起、激进的共和党（正如当时人们可能会称呼的那样，就像他所面对的那个“黑色共和党”）所代表的一切。罗伯特·E·李绝对、绝对不可能安心地去领导联邦军队，因为“他是完美英国绅士”这一点是他“人设”的重要部分，曾在战争期间被一位英国观察家这样比喻过。他有点像个“银发帅哥”，非常时髦。嗯，那其实是邦联的“人设”，汤姆。我的意思是，那真的是邦联的“人设”。我在我孩子的历史书里读到过——
yeah i read in the 1970s that was the confederacy's and so that's what that could cavaliers yeah and that is why lee... Could have Cavaliers. Yeah. And that is why Lee is the kind of... I mean, he's, in a sense, the Prince Rupert of the Confederacy. He's the dashing Cavalier. He's the emblem of it. But in essence, he is doing it because he wants to keep his children's inheritance safe. And that inheritance consists of plantations and of human property. Yeah. And the vision of America that he understands and that he understands he's inherited from his ancestors who fought in the revolution is one that fundamentally includes slavery.
我在1970年代读到过，那是邦联的——所以那就是那些骑士党。是的，这就是为什么李……可以被称为骑士党。是的，这就是为什么李是那种——我的意思是，从某种意义上说，他是邦联的鲁珀特亲王。他是风度翩翩的骑士党。他是邦联的象征。但本质上，他这样做是因为他想保护他孩子们的遗产。而那份遗产由种植园和人类财产组成。是的。而且他对美国的理解，以及他理解自己从参加革命的祖先那里继承下来的美国愿景，是一个从根本上包含奴隶制的愿景。
And as it were, what you know, why shouldn't it? Because that's what the republic has always done. And so he's standing against revolution, as he sees it. I mean, he could not conceive that a United States run by these new Republicans was going to be one that he would recognize. His world is about to end if the Republicans' vision for America dominates. And let's sort of pull back the camera back a bit. So by the summer of 1861, you have think 11 states in the confederate states of america um they've got a population of nine million people three and a half million of them or so are slaves and they are against 22 states in the union so the rump union if you like our usa i suppose you would call them, with 22 million people, but massive advantages in mills, factories, railroads,
而且，理所当然地，为什么不应该这样呢？因为这就是共和国一贯的做法。因此，在他看来，他是在对抗革命。我的意思是，他无法想象一个由这些新共和党人运作的合众国会是他所能认同的国家。如果共和党人对美国的愿景占据主导地位，他的世界就要走到头了。让我们稍微把镜头拉远一点。所以到1861年夏天，美利坚联盟国拥有11个州，它们拥有900万人口，其中大约350万是奴隶；而与之对立的是联邦的22个州，也就是所谓的残存联邦，或者你可以称之为美利坚合众国，拥有2200万人口，但在工厂、铁路、
and all those things. We know now, everybody listening to this knows that the union wins. Just to go through those facts and figures, it makes it sound like, okay, it's just like playing out a board game. You know, you've got all the cards. We've got two questions which go together well.
以及所有这些方面有着巨大的优势。我们现在都知道，听这节目的每个人都知道北方赢了。但仅仅通过这些事实和数据，听起来好像——好吧，这就像是在玩桌游一样。你知道的，你手里握着所有的牌。我们有两个很好的相关问题。
One is Grant Rogers, why did the union army lose so many battles at first? Spoiler alert, they do. And Will Randall, did the South stand a chance and was the north always going to win so i think those those questions kind of go together really because it's it's the fact that the north doesn't um win a kind of crushing victory initially that enables allows the war to go on but sets up the question of was the north always going to win i think the north was always going to win if it could stay the course if the war went on long enough for it to bring to bear its advantages
一个是格兰特·罗杰斯问的：“为什么联邦军队一开始会输掉那么多战役？”剧透一下，他们的确输了。另一个是威尔·兰德尔问的：“南方曾有过胜算吗？北方是不是注定会赢？”所以我觉得这两个问题其实可以结合在一起，因为正是因为北方一开始没有取得压倒性的胜利，才使得战争得以持续，这就引出了一个问题：北方是不是注定会赢？我认为，如果北方能够坚持到底——如果战争持续足够长的时间，让它能够发挥其在人员、物资、外交、领土以及其他所有方面的优势——如果战争持续足够长的时间，北方就注定会赢。但它可能并没有持续那么久，战争本可能更早结束。所以，我认为存在一些我们可以讨论的情景。我们可以想象除了北方最终获得的全面军事胜利之外的其他结局。我的意思是，亚当，难道全面军事胜利不是他们取胜的唯一途径吗？因为南方需要做的全部事情就是想方设法熬下去、坚持下去，他们最终就会赢，对吧？因为北方会妥协，然后——所以邦联的目标是说服北方，这不是一场他们能够以那种全面方式取得胜利的战争，这场战争不值得付出如此巨大的代价。因此，鉴于美利坚合众国是一个民主国家（尽管当时只有男性拥有投票权，而且主要是白人），南方需要做的就是说服普通北方民众，这场战争不值得一打。这就是南方必须做的事。而北方必须做的事，正如你所说，多米尼克，就是彻底摧毁南方——而这最终也正是他们所做的。但这花了他们四年的时间，花了他四年时间来调集他们占优的资源。所以在战争的最后阶段——在战争的最后一年，北方实际上进行的是一场消耗战，他们日复一日、年复一年地猛烈打击南方，在任何一场具体的战役中，他们阵亡的人数往往比南方还要多。但他们消耗得起。
in men and material and its diplomatic advantages and its territorial advantages and everything else if the war went on long enough but it might not have done it might have ended earlier than that so there are scenarios i think where you could which I think, which we can talk about. We can imagine scenarios short of the total military victory that the North in the end won. I mean, isn't that the only way they win, though, Adam, the total military victory? Because all the Confederacy has to do is just somehow plot along and keep keep going and they'll eventually win right because the north will settle and then so the confederate objectives are to persuade the north this isn't a war that they can that they can win in that total way that this it isn't worth the enormous cost so in the and therefore because the united States is a democracy, albeit only with, you know, with men voting and essentially white he had to do was to persuade ordinary northern people that this wasn't a war that was worth fighting that's what the south had to do what the north
如果在战争持续足够长的时间的话，北方在人力、物力、外交优势、领土优势以及其他方方面面都会占据上风，但战争也可能不会持续那么久，可能会更早结束，所以我认为存在一些我们可以讨论的设想。我们可以想象在北方最终取得全面军事胜利之外的其他可能性。我的意思是，亚当，难道全面军事胜利不是他们获胜的唯一途径吗？因为南方同盟只需要设法勉强支撑、继续抵抗，他们最终就会获胜，对吧？因为北方最终会妥协，所以南方同盟的目标是说服北方，让他们觉得这场战争是无法通过那种全面胜利的方式赢得的，觉得这不值得付出巨大的代价，因此，由于美国是一个民主国家，尽管当时只有男性（主要是白人）拥有投票权，南方需要做的就是说服普通的北方民众这场战争不值得进行，这就是南方必须要做到的，而北方
had to do as you say dominic is to completely destroy the south which in the end uh was was what they did but it took them four years and it took them four years to marshal their superior resources so by the very end of the war by by the final year of the war, the North was fighting essentially a war of attrition, which it was pummeling the South day after day after day after day, often losing more men than the South in any given battle. But it could afford to do so. Yeah. Okay. So Adam, one other way in which people say that the Confederacy, I mean, wouldn't have been able to hold out perhaps, is if the European powers, and perhaps particularly Britain, had entered the war on its side. So you mentioned about the Confederacy sending emissaries to Paris and to London. What would have happened if either the French or the
好的。那么，亚当，人们说邦联可能无法坚持下去的另一个原因是，如果欧洲列强（尤其是英国）站在他们这一边参战的话。所以你提到了邦联向巴黎和伦敦派遣特使。如果法国人或英国人站在邦联一边参战，会发生什么？这种可能性存在过吗？是的，所以这有点像是南方一直以来的“神兵天降”幻想，对吧？认为会有某种外国干预。毕竟，他们知道这会如何运作，因为他们可以回溯到美国独立战争，对吧？当时有一场战争，一群没有什么正规军的散兵游勇打败了世界上最强大的军事超级大国。我的意思是，那有多大胜算？嗯，他们做到这一点的方法之一，当然就是借助法国的军事援助。所以他们有一个现成的模板：再次让法国人介入，或者把英国人拉进来。
British had come in on the Confederate side? And was there ever any prospect of that happening? Yeah, so this is kind of always the sort of deus ex machina for the South, right? This notion that there would be some foreign intervention. And after all, they knew how this would work, because they could look back to the American War of Independence, right? So there was a war in which a bunch of sort of scrappy colonials with no proper army defeated the world's leading military superpower. I mean, what were the chances of that? Well, one of the ways in which they did it, of course, was with French military help. So they had a template there, get the French involved again, or get the Brits involved.
这样一来，军事平衡就瞬间改变了。而且他们有——你知道的，他们有很好的理由保持乐观。我的意思是，毕竟，如果——这显然是一个很大的假设——你把奴隶制从这个方程式中剔除，那么南方人在1861年所做的事就是争取民族自决。如果你是一个英国自由派，你知道的，如果你是格莱斯顿，或者更准确地说，如果你是理查德·科布登——如果你是《卫报》支持者理查德·科布登，你看向这一切时，你的大脑可能会“爆炸”，因为民族自决显然是正义的，就像
And all of a sudden, you change the military balance. And they had, you know, they had good reason for optimism. I mean, after all, if, and it's obviously a very big if, you take slavery out of the equation, then what the Southerners were doing in 1861 was national self-determination. If you're a British liberal, you know, if you're Gladstone, liberal you know if you're if you're gladstone or or more to the point if you're a guardian you're richard cobden yeah you look at this and you're kind of you know your head explodes because national self-determination obviously good like
有什么理由不呢？嗯，南方人支持自由贸易，他们反对贸易保护主义，这显然也是件好事。
what's not to like about that um the southerners support free trade they're anti-protectionist that's obviously good um but on the other hand, they're slaveholders, that's a bit of a problem. And so British liberals were in this genuine dilemma at the start of the war. But the fact that at the beginning of the war, Lincoln and the Union said, well, this is not a war to end slavery. This is just a war to keep the Union together, meant that there was space in British liberal radical circles to say, well, okay, if this really isn't a war to end slavery, then, and maybe as, you know, as Dominic was saying earlier, maybe actually slavery will come to an end earlier, if it's kind of quarantined in this new confederate. And then we can apply sanctions, we can use economic influence somehow or other, potentially,
但另一方面，他们是蓄奴者，这就有点问题了。因此，在战争爆发之初，英国自由派确实陷入了这种真正的两难境地。但事实是，在战争初期，林肯和联邦曾表示：“这并非一场旨在废除奴隶制的战争，这只是一场为了维护联邦统一的战争。”这意味着，在英国自由派和激进派的圈子里，存在着这样一种讨论空间：“好吧，如果这真的不是一场旨在废除奴隶制的战争，那么——正如多米尼克刚才所说的那样，也许奴隶制反而会更快终结，如果它被孤立在这个新的邦联之中的话。然后我们可以实施制裁，通过某种方式利用经济影响力，潜在地，我们可以对他们实施海上封锁，阻止新奴隶的输入，也许奴隶制就能更快地结束。”
we can blockade them, we can stop imports of new slaves, maybe slavery can end more quickly. But also, Adam, isn't it the case that you could argue it's in Britain's strategic interest to them we can stop imports of new slaves maybe slavery can end more quickly yeah but also uh adam isn't it the case that you could argue it's in britain's strategic interest to break up the united states i mean there are all fear there are fears all through the 19th century that there could be war between the united states and british north america you know what becomes canada so surely i mean isn't there an argument from kind of Palmerston and people like that? Listen, let's pile in, smash it all up. Great for us. We're even more top nation than we were already.
但是，亚当，难道不可以说，分裂合众国符合英国的战略利益吗？我的意思是，整个19世纪一直存在着一种恐惧，即美国与英属北美（也就是后来的加拿大）之间可能会爆发战争。所以，难道帕麦斯顿之流没有这种论调吗：“听着，我们加入进去，把美国彻底粉碎。这对我们太有利了。我们会比以前更加成为世界第一大国。
The pesky colonials have been taught a lesson. And it's pretty much what the French are doing in Mexico, right? So we did an episode on the extraordinary French adventure in Mexico. And that basically is an attempt to try and set up a french zone of influence while the americans are distracted yeah since the french are already militarily engaged in in north america with this bizarre intervention in in mexico um napoleon the third is probably more likely to come in on in support of the Confederacy in the end than Britain. Everything you say is totally right, Dominic, about the kind of schadenfreude and the kind of gleeful enjoyment of the of the Americans going to war with one another in 1861.
那些讨厌的殖民地居民该给点教训了。”这不正是法国人在墨西哥所做的事情吗？所以我们做过一期关于法国在墨西哥那场非凡冒险的节目。那基本上就是法国人试图在美利坚人分身乏术之际建立一个法国势力范围的尝试。是的，既然法国人已经通过对墨西哥那场离奇的军事干预卷入了北美事务，拿破仑三世最终支持邦联的可能性，可能比英国人还要大。多米尼克，你关于那种幸灾乐祸以及1861年美国人自相残杀时英国人那种幸灾乐祸的种种说法完全正确。
But what the countervailing factors that meant that in the end, I actually kind of, you know, to answer your question, was Britain ever likely to intervene on the part of the Confederacy? I think no is the answer. What were the countervailing factors? Well, one of them was the City of London and the massive amounts of investment that had been made in United States railroads. And that all would have been put at jeopardy if Britain then had to go to war with the United States, which presumably would have been put at jeopardy if Britain then had to go to war with the United States, which presumably would have been the inevitable consequence of intervention in support of the Confederacy. And the second one in the end was slavery. In the end, as it became clearer and clearer that union victory in the war would deal likely an irreparable
但是，有哪些对立因素意味着最终——为了回答你的问题，英国是否曾经有可能介入并支持邦联？我认为答案是否定的。那么，有哪些对立因素呢？其中之一就是伦敦金融城以及在美利坚铁路中投入的大量资本。如果英国随后不得不与美国开战，所有这些投资都将陷入危急境地——而这presumably（假定）会是英国介入支持邦联的必然结果。而第二个因素，归根结底还是奴隶制。最终，随着局势越来越清晰地表明，联邦在战争中的胜利很可能会给奴隶制带来致命打击，英国政府要想采取任何实质性行动去支持一个亲奴隶制的共和国，就变得越来越难以想象了。
blow to slavery, it became harder and harder to imagine how a british government would do anything to actively support a pro-slavery republic yeah and that among the liberals as you say that i mean they can't do it really can they deep down they can't pile in to support slaveholders because because although as cynical and as ruthless as lots of liberal politicians are they are as tom would say they are deeply christian and um well um i think we should take a break at this point uh when we come back i think we should look at the actual course of the war so we've we've kind of alluded to the fact that uh basically it's confederate successes all the way and effectively that establishes a stalemate.
是的，正如你所说，在自由派当中，他们真的做不到这一点，从内心深处，他们无法跳出来支持蓄奴者。因为尽管许多自由派政客同样愤世嫉俗、冷酷无情，但正如汤姆所说，他们有着深厚的基督教信仰，而且……嗯，我想我们现在应该休息一下了。等我们回来后，我想我们应该探讨一下战争的实际进程——我们之前已经暗示过，基本上早期全都是邦联的胜利，这实际上造成了一种僵局。
I hope I've got that right. Tom, am I not right in thinking for any listeners who attempted to disappear, you're also going to be talking about cricket? Possibly, but I don't want to scare any remaining American listeners. All right, see you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment
希望我没理解错。汤姆，对于任何想要溜号的听众来说，我是不是没记错的话，你接下来还要谈板球？有可能，但我不想吓跑剩下的任何美国听众。好吧，休息过后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐至死》
it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works
这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。
we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to therestisentertainment.com that's
我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家加更节目以及抢先购买现场门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。
therestisentertainment.com dot com that's the rest is entertainment dot com welcome back to the rest is history we've been talking about the american civil war we've been talking about how it started uh why people chose sides and why britain did not get involved now adam um tom and i were discussing this before we started recording and the complexity we are not military historians by any means and the complexity of the sort of battle narrative i think our puny minds struggle to kind of explode yeah to compute explode so so am i right in are we right in thinking that basically this it's a stalemate for the first 18 months or so in which the confederates probably win more battles than the than the union is that about right the only problem i have with the word stalemate is that implies there isn't any movement any territorial gains and and and there is um so if you if you in
网址是 therestisentertainment.com。这就是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们一直在讨论美国内战，探讨它是如何爆发的、人们为何选择各自阵营，以及英国为什么没有介入。现在，亚当，汤姆和我录制前讨论过，战争叙事的复杂性——我们绝不是军事史学家，这种战役叙事的复杂性让我们这些薄弱的大脑很难去理清、去消化。所以，我的理解对吗——我们的理解对吗？基本上，在最初的18个月左右，这是一个僵局，在此期间邦联赢得的战役可能比联邦还要多，差不多是这样吗？我对“僵局”这个词唯一的意见是，它暗示着没有任何军事移动或领土得失，但实际上是有的。
the in the western theater i mean the union makes some significant gains i mean new orleans um falls to well the union navy plays in Key World there in the spring of 1862. Much of the Mississippi Valley is under Union control. So I think stalemate would be an exaggeration. But if you look at the Virginia Theatre, so inevitably a lot of the battles were focused on this area between the two capitals, Richmond and Washington. And that was the place that it was easier for news reporters to get to. That was where Robert E. Lee was in by the spring of 62,
所以，如果你在西部战场——我是说，联邦取得了一些重大的进展。新奥尔良——落入联邦海军手中，联邦海军在1862年春天控制了基韦斯特。密西西比河谷的大部分地区也处于联邦的控制之下。所以我觉得用“僵局”来形容会有所夸张。但如果你看看弗吉尼亚战场——不可避免地，许多战役都集中在里士满和华盛顿这两个首都之间的区域。那是新闻记者更容易到达的地方。那是罗伯特·E·李在1862年春天被任命指挥邦联军队（北弗吉尼亚军团）的地方。所以那是战争中最具光彩的区域。而且确实，在整个1862年的春夏季，都是邦联一路掌控主动权。所以李是那种“海报男孩”（风云人物），但另一个“海报男孩”是斯通沃尔·杰克逊。汤姆很喜欢斯通沃尔·杰克逊，亚当。
was put in command of Confederate forces, the Army of Northern Virginia. So that was the kind of, that was the glamour end of the war. And certainly throughout the spring and summer of 1862 it was the confederates uh in the driving seat all the way so lee is the kind of the poster boy but the other poster boy for that is um stonewall jackson tom loves stonewall jackson adam well i don't love i but tom has a very soft spot, I know I don't want to get you cancelled, Tom, because having soft spots for Confederate generals is quite dodgy. But I know you have a torn dress for Stonewall Jackson.
哦，我可不——但汤姆对斯通沃尔·杰克逊有着极其软弱的一面。我知道，我可不想让你被“取消文化”抵制，汤姆，因为对邦联将军抱有好感是一件相当棘手的事。但我知道你对斯通沃尔·杰克逊情有独钟。
Well, so a question from Brad Smith. How should history view figures like Robert E. Lee and Stonewall Jackson? We'll come to that in due course. I think Stonewall Jackson is kind of an interesting figure, isn't he? Because the archetype of the Confederate general is, well, cavalier. Long hair. Long hair, kind of dashing, all that kind of stuff. Stable Jackson is slightly made of sterner stuff.
那么，布拉德·史密斯提出了一个问题：“历史应当如何看待罗伯特·E·李和斯通沃尔·杰克逊这样的人物？”我们稍后会适时讨论。我觉得斯通沃尔·杰克逊是一个相当有趣的人物，不是吗？因为邦联将军的典型形象是——嗯，骑士党。长发。长发飘飘、风度翩翩，诸如此类。斯通沃尔·杰克逊则有点不同，他是用更坚硬的材料塑造的。
I mean, he is a more Cromwellian figure. He is, you know, he teaches black children at sunday school and all that kind of thing uh and the fact that he he gets the nickname doesn't he because um in the very first battle at bull run um there's the threat that the confederate line will give way and he stands still and he's compared to a stone wall um am i right in seeing him as as a kind of distinctive a distinctive figure or is he just part of this blur of kind of dashing morally dubious confederate generals there is something about stonewall jackson isn't that i mean my mother-in-law like you is a big is a big fan of stonewall jackson i just go on the record i wouldn't describe myself as a big fan
我的意思是，他是一个更具克伦威尔色彩的人物。他（你知道的）在主日学校教黑人儿童读书，诸如此类。而且他获得这个绰号的原因是——在第一次布尔Run战役中，邦联的防线面临崩溃的危险，而他静静地站在那里，被人们比作一堵“石墙”。我把他看作一个独特的人物，还是他只是这群风度翩翩、道德上可疑的邦联将军中的一员？斯通沃尔·杰克逊身上确实有一种独特的气质，不是吗？我的意思是，我的岳母和你一样，是斯通沃尔·杰克逊的超级大粉丝。我必须声明，我不会把自己描述成他的超级大粉丝，
but he does seem an intriguing figure he is an intriguing figure he sucks lemons i believe yeah he goes into battle there's been a lot of talk about that hasn't there about whether he ate lemons or whatever yeah yeah and peaches as well i gather yeah um so yeah i i've never quite thought about it as he he complicates the the the cavalier um roundhead divide but you're totally right tom that he does because he is he is he's a kind of roundhead figure in a in a in a cavalier army and maybe that's what makes him stand out among confederate generals i never quite thought about it like that before but i think you're right but adam is it is it i mean so that the the stereotypical view and actually you get this right at the end of the war the surrender surrender at Appomattox Courthouse, Ulysses S. Grant, the Union commander,
但他确实显得很引人入胜。他确实是个引人入胜的人物。我相信他很喜欢嚼柠檬。是的，他上战场时会带着——关于这一点有很多讨论，不是吗？关于他是否吃柠檬之类的，是的，还有桃子，我听说也是。所以，是的，我从没太把这看作是他混淆了“骑士党”与“圆颅党”的阵营界限，但汤姆，你完全说对了，他的确做到了这一点，因为他是一个骑士党军队里的圆颅党式人物，也许正是这一点让他在一众邦联将军中脱颖而出。我以前从没这样想过，但我觉得你是对的。不过，亚当，这是不是——也就是说，刻板印象——事实上你在战争刚结束时就能看到这一点：在阿帕马克斯法院的投降仪式上，联邦指挥官尤利西斯·S·格兰特是一个满身泥泞、衣着寒酸的人物，而罗伯特·E·李则穿着他最好的制服、戴着漂亮的帽子，诸如此类。那是19世纪70年代儿童读物版的战争，也是我认为20世纪很多美国人在成长过程中接触到的关于骑士党的版本。我们可以在后期的节目中讨论邦联的“失落的因由”（Lost Cause）神话。这一切难道全都是无稽之谈吗？我的意思是，这些都是蓄奴者，这些都是蓄奴者，这些人当中有些是职业军人——他们可不仅仅是那种涂脂抹粉、《乱世佳人》风格、留着大长发的花花公子，对吧？不，他们绝对不是。
is all kind of muddy and shabby figure, and Robert E. Lear's in his best uniform and a nice hat and all this sort of stuff. And that's the 1970s kind of children's book version of the war, and the version that I think a lot of americans in the 20th century grew up with is that cavalier stuff i mean we can get in in a later episode i think to the lost cause the confederacy is that all just nonsense i mean these are slave owners these are slave holders these people some of the professional military men i mean they're not just sort of simpering gone with the wind style fops with big hair, are they? No, they're definitely not.
无论这一切是否成立，都取决于你想如何看待“骑士党与圆颅党”的二元对立。因为我认为，在文化、宗教和气质上，这种说法确实有一定道理：这是一群人进行的一场看似绝望的努力——在回溯过去时，它似乎是那些捍卫一套陈旧价值观体系的人，在对抗一支更加现代化的军队时所做出的徒劳抵抗。所以，如果你所说的“骑士党与圆颅党”的分裂就是这个意思，那么我认为它确实有几分道理。但当然，你是对的，这些人——尤其是北弗吉尼亚军团的军官阶层——绝大多数都是蓄奴者或蓄奴者的后代。
Whether or not it all falls depends on what you kind of want to do with this cavalier roundhead dichotomy because I think, you know, culturally, religiously, temperamentally, there is, I think, some truth in the notion that this is, is you know this is a forlorn um this is a what what seems in retrospect to be a full forlorn effort by people who are um defending a kind of older system of values uh against a more modern army so if you know if that's what you mean by the cavalier roundhead division then i think there is some truth to it. But of course, you're right that these people are, I mean, the officer class in particular, anyway, in the Army of Northern Virginia are overwhelmingly slaveholders or the sons of slaveholders.
不过，让我们来聊聊第一阶段的经历。马克思在评论中曾将其描述为一种现代战争——这是一场充满新鲜事物的战争，但也正因为如此，它是一场可怕的战争，对士兵而言，不是吗？把它看作是一场有点像第一次世界大战的战争，是不是不太切实际？战争中有很多泥泞，你知道的，你会遭到榴弹炮袭击，战线后方有着严重的疾病，环境极其恶劣。参战的士兵们自己是怎么想的？它确实变得越来越像第一次世界大战了。
But let's talk a bit about the experience of the first episode in his mark in his beautiful car marks quotation was about it as a sort of modern as it's the first modern war it's it's a war full of novelty but that makes it a horrible war isn't it as a soldier i mean is it too fanciful to see it as a little bit you know there's a lot of it's very first world war at times there's an awful lot of mud. There is, you know, you're being hit by shrapnel. There's a lot of disease behind the lines. The conditions are horrible. What do the men themselves think of it? It becomes more and more like the First World War.
但我们来聊聊第一集的经历以及卡尔·马克思那段精彩的引言，关于它作为一种现代战争——这是第一场现代战争，充满了新奇之处，但这让它成了一场可怕的战争，不是吗？作为一名士兵，我的意思是，如果把它看作有点像——你知道的，有时它非常像第一次世界大战，有很多泥泞，你知道的，会被榴弹击发，后方有大量疾病，条件非常糟糕。士兵们自己是怎么看待它的？它变得越来越像第一次世界大战。
So if we were transported now to outside Petersburg and Virginia in August 1864, we'd see entrenchments barbed wire proto machine guns we'd see um union mining engineers tunneling under confederate lines in order to blow holes underneath in order to try to engineer in advance, just like on the Western Front. It's also Napoleonic, right, as well, though. Right, exactly. Because you've got cavalry, you've got Custer, you've got Jeb Stuart. And that's why it's a classic transition war.
所以，如果我们现在被传送到1864年8月的彼得堡和弗吉尼亚州外围，我们会看到战壕、铁丝网、原始机枪，还会看到北军的工兵在同盟军防线下方凿隧道，以便在下方炸出洞来，从而试图在战前进行工程作业，就像西线战场上那样。不过，它同时也有拿破仑时代的特点，对吧？没错，完全如此。因为有骑兵，有卡斯特（Custer），有杰布·斯图尔特（Jeb Stuart）。正因如此，这是一场典型的过渡战争。
And so certainly through most of 1861, 62, 63, you wouldn't have seen much or any of that. You would have seen some entrenchments in some places, but you certainly would have seen some entrenchments in some places but you certainly would have seen uh cavalry charges and all through and really right up until the end of the war this continuing faith that bayonet charges the kind of cult of the bayonet charge as the great glamorous decisive moment that's going to that's going to let's wait because we'll talk about that in the context of gettysburg which perhaps we'll do in the next
所以在1861、62、63年的大部分时间里，你肯定不会看到太多甚至根本看不到这些。你会在某些地方看到一些战壕，但你肯定会看到一些战壕，不过你肯定会看到呃骑兵冲锋，而且贯穿始终，直到战争结束，人们依然坚信刺刀冲锋——这种刺刀冲锋崇拜——是那种能带来决定性胜利的光鲜亮丽的时刻，这将——这将——等一下，因为我们会在葛底斯堡的背景下讨论这一点，也许我们会在下一期
episode um we've talked about the experience of men in the war could we also talk about the experience of women so one of the things that makes to go back to my old friend stonewall jackson interesting is that his sister is a very, very keen abolitionist and goes on the union side. So that's kind of representative perhaps of families divided. Is that common? Is there a kind of, you know, is that sense of a gender divide one that is common or is that distinctive to Jackson's family? And more generally, what is the role that women are playing? Because as I understand it, it's unusually heightened relative to earlier wars, the role that women play. Yes, women are very involved in both sides, in helping to undermine the war effort. So, for example, by the summer of 1863,
节目中讨论。呃，我们讨论了战争中男人们的经历，我们能谈谈女人们的经历吗？所以，回到我老朋友石墙杰克逊（Stonewall Jackson）身上，让这变得有趣的一点是，他的妹妹是一位非常、非常坚定的废奴主义者，并加入了北军一方。所以这也许有点像是分裂家庭的缩影。这很常见吗？这种性别分裂的感觉很常见吗？还是杰克逊家族所特有的？更广泛地说，女性扮演了什么角色？据我所理解，相对于以往的战争，女性扮演的角色异常突出。是的，女性在双方都非常活跃，参与破坏战争努力。比如，到1863年夏天，
women on the home front in the South who were suffering severe shortages of bread and other basic foodstuffs, and in the context of massive Weimar Germany-style inflation, are out on the streets rioting and encouraging desertion from the Confederate Army in some places. But at the same time, they're also the embodiment, women are projected as being the kind of embodiment
南方后方的女性正遭受着严重的面包和其他基本食品短缺，在类似于魏玛德国式的恶性通货膨胀背景下，她们走上街头骚乱，并在某些地方煽动南方邦联军队逃兵。但与此同时，女性也是爱国事业的化身，在双方都被塑造成了这种化身。
of the patriotic cause on both sides. And so as in other modern wars, both the imagined reality of the role that women are playing, but also the actual material reality as nurses and as volunteers and as the people who are sustaining the war effort back home. Right, so people are running the farms and things. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's hugely important.
就像在其他现代战争中一样，女性扮演的角色的想象现实，以及作为护士、志愿者以及在后方维持战争努力的人的实际物质现实。对，所以人们在经营农场之类的事情。对，对，对。这极其重要。
So the men are away from home. They're riddled with disease. A lot of them presumably, I mean, prostitution. There must be camp followers with the two armies, Adam? Yeah, yeah. And General Hooker, of course, is supposedly the person who most encouraged or at least turned a blind eye to camp followers. And, you know, his name was attached to some of them. The word hooker comes from General Hooker.
所以男人们都不在家。他们浑身是病。他们当中很多人大概——我的意思是，卖淫。这两支军队里一定有随军家属吧，亚当？对，对。当然，胡克将军（General Hooker）被认为是最鼓励随军家属或至少对他们睁一只眼闭一只眼的人，而且，你知道，他的名字和其中一些人联系在了一起。“胡克”（hooker，意为妓女）这个词就源自胡克将军。
Well, I've learned something absolutely splendid. That is fascinating. OK, so when people are not consorting with Ladies of the Night, of course, what they should be doing is playing cricket. I mean, everyone knows that. And cricket is very, very popular in the United States prior to the Civil War. Where does it all go wrong? Cricket is the forgotten casualty of the American Civil War.
好吧，我学到了一件绝对精彩的事。这太迷人了。好吧，所以当人们不跟夜间女郎鬼混时，当然，他们应该做的是打板球。我的意思是，大家都知道这一点。而且在南北战争之前，板球在美国非常、非常受欢迎。这一切是从哪里开始出问题的呢？板球是美国南北战争中被遗忘的牺牲品。
And I'm glad that on this podcast, we're going to restore it to its central central place as you will know better than me Tom in in 1859 there was an England tour of North America I think they they played three matches against uh United States 22 uh in the Americans have twice as many players yeah they did and I don't know I mean tell me presumably they didn't have 22 people actually on the field they must have they had 22 people batting that would be too bad but only but only 11 but only 11 fielding england won all three of those matches anyway one in one in new jersey across the across the river from new york uh one in in boston one in philadelphia and they also played two matches against upper canada i think on the same tour and and cricket was indeed a very popular summer game and that England tour really kind of brought it into the public attention and the new illustrated press
我很高兴在这个播客中，我们将恢复它核心的、核心的地位，正如你比我更清楚的，汤姆，在1859年有一支英格兰代表队到北美巡回比赛，我想他们与美国队进行了三场比赛，美国队有22名球员——美国人有两倍多的球员。对，他们确实有，我不知道——我是说，告诉我，大概他们实际上并没有22个人在球场上吧？他们一定有，他们有22个人击球，那就太糟糕了，但只有——但只有11个人，但只有11个人在防守。英格兰赢了所有这三场比赛，不管怎样，一场在纽约河对岸的新泽西，一场在波士顿，一场在费城。我想他们在同一次巡回赛中还与上加拿大（Upper Canada）打了两场比赛，板球确实是一项非常受欢迎的夏季运动，那次英格兰巡回赛确实把它带入了公众视野，新的画报新闻界
was all over it and yeah it was a big thing and fast forward six years the end of the American Civil War and and cricket struggling and and and it's never really recovered. I think there was another England cricket tour in 1868. Is that right? But it didn't have anything like the same impact as the 1859 tour. And baseball has taken over, right? Baseball has taken over. And, you know, one of the reasons for this is that baseball is a quicker game. Yeah.
对此进行了大量报道，对，这是一件大事。快进六年，美国南北战争结束，板球陷入困境，而且再也没有真正恢复过。我想在1868年还有另一次英格兰板球巡回赛，是这样吗？但它的影响完全无法与1859年的巡回赛相提并论。棒球已经取代了它，对吧？棒球已经取代了它。而且，你知道，原因之一是棒球是一项更快的运动。对。
Also because it doesn't require – We can all agree. It's basically a children's game yeah also because it doesn't require it doesn't we can all agree it's basically a children's game isn't it i mean it's a children's game let's be let's be frank about it and it doesn't require because you don't have to um you don't have to you don't have to roll out a pitch because the ball doesn't bounce does it when you when you pitch in baseball the ball doesn't actually pitch uh so uh therefore um baseball was easier to play in in army camps um where um where it might have been harder to play cricket so i i do think this is there are if you search through the official records of the war of the rebellion um looking for which is the huge compilation of all of the reports written by you know by by officers throughout the whole of the
还有因为不需要——我们都可以同意，它基本上是个儿童游戏，对，还有因为它不需要——我们都可以同意，它基本上是个儿童游戏，不是吗？我的意思是，它是个儿童游戏，我们直说吧，坦白讲。而且它不需要——因为你不需要——你不需要铺设球场，因为球不会反弹，不是吗？当你在棒球中投球时，球实际上并不是投出来的——所以，因此，棒球在军队营地里更容易玩，而在那些地方，玩板球可能会更难。所以我确实认为——如果你在“叛乱战争”的官方记录中搜寻——寻找那些由战争整整四年里各级军官撰写的所有报告的庞大汇编——会有一些关于板球的零星参考，
four years of the war there are a few scattered references to cricket um there were a few cricket games played between regiments um especially in the earlier of the war but it but it becomes it's eclipsed by baseball it's a terrible thing it's like the the the uh the cricket tour to uh france that was projected in 1789 the great events of world history keep getting in the way so so sad so sad so let's get back to the great events what happens over the course of 1862 so the very first episode we had carl marx looking at you know in in awe at the spectacle of these vast armies kind of ignorant armies clashing by night what is going on what can what
在各个团之间举行过一些板球比赛，特别是在战争初期，但它——但它被棒球黯然失色了。这太糟糕了，就像1789年计划对法国进行的板球巡回赛一样，世界历史上的重大事件总是不断从中作梗。太悲伤了，太悲伤了。所以让我们回到重大事件上来。1862年期间发生了什么？所以我们第一集的开场是卡尔·马克思（Karl Marx）惊叹于这些庞大军队的壮观景象，这些无知的军队在夜间互相厮杀。到底发生了什么？能不能
just give us a very quick kind of resume of what of the campaigning so um in the west the union army is making advances down the mississippi valley capturing new orleans which is really critically important because that cuts it in two right it doesn't it's not fully cut into until the summer of 1863 when Vicksburg falls. But the Union is making territorial gains in Tennessee and in Arkansas and in Louisiana. Meanwhile, in the east, in Virginia, Robert E. Lee's Army of Northern Virginia is kind of running rings around the the union army so so the first uh or not the first but the but the first union uh commander to make a serious effort to uh try to win the war is general mcclellan who has this idea that he will kind of float the union army down to the james river and advance on richmond from the east um along the peninsula.
给我们简单总结一下战事？所以，在西部，北军正沿着密西西比河谷推进，占领了新奥尔良，这绝对至关重要，因为它把它（南方）切成了两半，对吧？直到1863年夏天维克斯堡（Vicksburg）陷落，它才被完全切断。但北军在田纳西州、阿肯色州和路易斯安那州取得了领土收益。与此同时，在东部，在弗│吉尼亚州，罗伯特·E·李（Robert E. Lee）的北弗吉尼亚军团正在北军周围兜圈子，所以第一个——或者说不是第一个，但北军第一位认真努力试图赢得战争的指挥官是麦克莱伦将军（General McClellan），他有一个想法，就是把北军顺流送到詹姆斯河，并沿着半岛从东面向里士满推进。
Because otherwise he's got this problem. There are all these rivers that are running eastward, cutting off a direct north-south assault from Washington to Richmond. So this is his clever idea. But he is defeated by General Lee in what are known as the Seven Days Battles in the summer of 1862. And Lee then audaciously follows up on these important battles a slave state, but one that has not seceded. It's basically been held within the Union kind of by force of arms. incredibly um audacious effort but it goes back to this core objective of the confederacy that
因为否则他会遇到这个问题。所有这些河流都向东流，切断了从华盛顿到里士满的直接南北进攻。所以这是他的聪明主意。但在1862年夏天被称为“七日战役”（Seven Days Battles）的战斗中，他被李将军击败了。随后，李将军大胆地跟进了这些重要的战斗：一个蓄奴州，但没有脱离联邦。它基本上是通过武力被维持在联邦内的。这是一个令人难以置信的大胆举动，但它回到了我们之前讨论过的邦联的核心目标，即
we talked about earlier which is to persuade the north that this is not a war that in the end they can win because if they can win with this offensive campaign adam the war's been going on for more than a year lee presumably thinks if we can lay waste maryland you know smash the union arm is the union just give up they'll realize they can't ever beat us yeah he kind of also hopes as well that that maryland being a slave state will kind of rise up in support of the confederacy augment his army and he can then move further from maryland into pennsylvania maybe even into new jersey who knows did he did he hope to capture washington itself he said yes i mean i mean that was within the that would have been the you know the outside the most ambitious objective or at least to encircle washington because washington is very
说服北方，这场战争他们最终是赢不了的。因为如果他们能通过这次进攻性战役取胜，亚当，战争已经打了韦一年多了，李大概认为，如果我们能蹂躏马里兰州，你知道，粉碎北军，联邦就会放弃吗？他们会意识到他们永远无法击败我们。对，他大概也希望马里兰州作为一个蓄奴州会奋起支持邦联，扩充他的军队，然后他可以从马里兰州进一步推进到宾夕法尼亚州，甚至可能进入新泽西州，谁知道呢？他——他希望占领华盛顿本身吗？他说过，是的，我的意思是，那是——那将是最雄心勃勃的目标，或者至少是包围华盛顿，因为华盛顿非常
vulnerable of course surrounded by slave states i mean it's a it's a federal district um which slavery um was legal on the eve of the war um there was one impossible to imagine that confederates could have encircled washington and that clearly would have been very, very dangerous for the Union. And the bloodiest of all the battles is Antietam. Is that right? Bloodiest single day. Yes. The Battle of Towton of the American history, as I like to think of it. Yes. Yes. And that's a battle that is essentially a really bloody draw. So that's very First World War. Well, except it was a battle in a day. So that's very First World War.
脆弱，当然四周都是蓄奴州。我的意思是，这是一个联邦区，在战争前夜蓄奴在那里是合法的，不可能想象邦联本可以包围华盛顿，那对联邦来说显然会非常、非常危险。安提坦（Antietam）战役是所有战役中最血腥的吗？是这样吗？单日最血腥。是的。我喜欢称之为美国历史上的陶顿（Towton）战役。是的。是的。那基本上是一场极其血腥的平局。所以这非常像第一次世界大战。好吧，除了这是一场在一之内发生的战斗。所以这就不那么像第一次世界大战了，对吧？好吧，好吧，好吧。李将军运气简直糟透了，联邦的作战计划被一名传令兵弄丢了，并被一个北军间谍捡到。所以北军指挥官麦克莱伦将军实际上确切地知道了邦联军队要去哪里。这给了他们巨大的优势。
Well, except it was a battle in a day. That isn't so First World War, is it? Okay, all right, okay. General Lee had this incredible stroke of bad luck, which is that Confederate battle plans were lost by a dispatch rider and picked up by a Union spy. And so General McClellan, the Union commander, actually knew exactly where the Confederate army was going to be. It gave them a huge advantage.
即便如此，这仍然不能算是一场完全具有决定性的北军胜利，但它确实阻止了那种令人惊叹的、不可避免的南方戏剧性胜利的感觉，因为安提坦绝对不是那种胜利。由于这场战斗，李的军队撤回了弗吉尼亚。但它的另一个重大结果，我想是——所以我们之前谈了很多亚伯拉罕·林肯（Abraham Lincoln），而在这一集中我们没有怎么谈论他，但这段时间林肯一直很不耐烦，对吧？因为他希望麦克莱伦，他的指挥官，
Even so, it was less than a fully decisive Union victory, but it still stopped this kind of sense of kind of awe-inspiring inevitability of dramatic southern victories because Antietam was definitely not that. And as a result of it, Lee's army retreated back into Virginia. But the other big result of it, I guess, is that... So we talked about Abraham Lincoln a lot before, and we haven't talked about him so much in this episode, but all this time Lincoln has been chafing, hasn't he? Because he wanted MacLennan, his commander,
发动一场更类似于全面战争的战争。麦克莱伦一直在唠叨要按照基督教原则打仗，要对人友善之类的事情，而不是攻击心灵战略——是的，林肯显然认为这完全是白费力气，对吧？因为林肯头脑清醒得多。但林肯，你刚才提到林肯在开始时说过，这不是一场旨在终结奴役制的战争。我的意思是，当我们现在回想起来，当我们把这场战争视为一场旨在终结奴役制的战争时，这是一件多么非同寻常的事情。所以林肯是否一直渴望一个机会，一场胜利，以便他能够改变战争的性质？
to wage a much more sort of total war McLennan was sort of wittering about fighting a war on Christian principles and being kind to people and stuff and not attacking the mind strategy yeah which obviously Lincoln thought was a complete dead loss didn't he because Lincoln is much more clear-sighted but Lincoln you mentioned before Lincoln had said at beginning, it's not a war to end slavery. I mean, an extraordinary thing to say when we look back at it now, when we think of the war as a war to end slavery. So has Lincoln been itching for an opportunity, for one victory, so that he can change the terms of the war?
或者你认为，亚当，他发布——因为他最终颁布了《解放奴隶宣言》（Emancipation Proclamation）来解放奴隶，他是出于绝望才这么做的吗？还是因为他一直都想这么做？他一直都希望奴役制结束。但这并不是说他在敌对行动一开始脑子里就有了一个清晰的计划。如果——我们设想一下，如果麦克莱伦是一个更好的将军，或者李将军是一个更糟的将军，1862年春天的半岛战役取得了成功，里士满在1862年5月、6月或7月陷落了。并且我们设想如果发生了这种情况，这对南方来说是一个如此巨大的士气打击，以至于几个南方州说，好吧，游戏结束了。让我们重新加入联邦。
Or do you think, Adam, or does he issue, because he comes to issue the Emancipation Proclamation freeing slaves, does he do that in desperation? Or does he do that because he's always wanted to do it? He has always wanted slavery to end. But it's not that he had a clear plan in his mind from the outset of hostilities. If, let's just imagine, McClellan had been a better general, or General Lee had been a worse general, and the Peninsular Campaign in the spring of 1862 had been a better general or General Lee had been a worse general and the Peninsula Campaign in the spring of 1862 had been successful and Richmond had fallen in May or June or July of 1862. And let's just imagine that if that happened, that was such a morale blow to the South that several southern states said, okay, the game's up. Let's rejoin the union.
如果发生了这种情况，并且战争以某种方式结束了，那么奴役制仍然会存在。林肯将不得不忍受这一点——不仅仅是忍受。林肯会认为这是一场伟大的政治胜利。他反对奴役制的斗争无疑会继续下去。他不会改变对奴役制的看法，但如果战争能以某种方式——如果能以拯救联邦的方式结束，或者如果能通过某种方式结束的话，战争很容易就会结束。
If that had happened and somehow the war had come to an end, then slavery still would have existed. And Lincoln would have had to put up with that more than put up with that. Lincoln would have regarded that as a great political victory. His struggle against slavery, no doubt would have continued. He wouldn't have changed his mind about slavery, but the war could easily have come to an end if it had if it had saved the union or could have come to an end if
如果有办法在奴役制完好无缺的同时拯救联邦，林肯在给北方报纸编辑霍勒斯·格里利（Horace Greeley）的一封信中也曾明确表示过，他说，如果我能通过解放所有奴隶来拯救联邦，我会这么做。如果我能通过解放其中一部分人而不管其他人来拯救联邦，我也会这么做。如果我能不解放任何奴隶来拯救联邦，我也会这么做。所以联邦对他来说确实更重要。他所做的一切都是为了拯救联邦。
there'd been a way of saving it while still while slavery remained intact lincoln said as much in terms in a letter he wrote to a northern newspaper editor horace greeley in which he said if i could save the union by freeing all the slaves i would said, if I could save the Union by freeing all the slaves, I would do it. If I could save the Union by freeing some of them and leaving others alone, I would do that. If I could save the Union without freeing any slaves, I would do that too. So the Union genuinely matters more to him. What he's doing is saving the Union.
问题是，当他写那封信的时候，他其实已经写好并签署了初步《解放奴隶宣言》的草稿，但他把它锁在书桌抽屉里了。他没有将其公之于众。所以，甚至在他宣称他所做的一切都是为了拯救联邦的同时，他也清楚事情的发展方向。而他之所以没有——这是在1862年的夏天的7月、8月，他之所以当时没有将初步的《解放奴隶宣言》公之于众，正是因为，正如你刚才所说，多米尼克，这可能会被视为绝望。对。
Now, the thing is, when he wrote that letter, though, he had already written and signed a draft of the preliminary emancipation proclamation, but he'd locked it in his desk drawer. He hadn't made it public. So even while he's saying everything I do, I do to save the union, he knows the way this is going. And the reason why he hadn't, this is in the summer of July, August 1862, and the reason why he hadn't made the preliminary Emancipation Proclamation public at that point was precisely because, as you just said, Dominic, it might be perceived as desperation. Right. And then maybe it would be counterproductive. Maybe then it would actually convince European powers that, oh, my God, if they're needing to do this, then the Union is really on the back foot. And so perhaps they kind of win a victory in September at Antietam in Maryland,
然后也许这会适得其反。也许那样反而会让欧洲列强确信：“哦，天哪，如果他们连这招都得用，那联邦真的是在走下坡路了。”所以也许他们在9月马里兰州的安提坦赢得了一场胜利——也就是你刚才一直在谈论的那场。正是在这种背景下，林肯才颁布了这份初步的《解放奴隶宣言》。我们之前说过，很多人既是废奴主义者，却又非常种族主义。当然，北方也有很多人可能不是废奴主义者，正如历史中经常出现的那样。可能还有很多人根本不在乎奴役制
which you've just been talking about. And so it's on the back of that that Lincoln issues this preliminary emancipation proclamation. And we were saying before that lots of people were abolitionists and yet were very racist. And, of course, there are lots of people in the North who probably aren't abolitionists, as so often in history. There are probably lots of people who couldn't care less about slavery
倾向哪一边。他们会被这种革命性的举动吓到吗？——我的意思是，鉴于我们在第一集里讨论过的所有内容，这场关于奴役制未来的痛苦、折磨般的争论，突然之间林肯就像是——砰，对了，就是这样。通过行政命令，我正在解放所有奴隶。把废奴事业搞定。是的，把废奴事业搞定。他就像他那该死的鲍里斯（Boris）风格一样，一路撞碎聚苯乙烯泡沫块。
one way or the other. Are they alarmed by such a revolutionary – I mean, given everything we talked about in the first episode, this torturous, gruelling argument about the future of slavery, and suddenly Lincoln is like, bang, right, that's it. Through executive action, I am emancipating all the slaves. Getting abolitionism done. Yeah, let's get abolitionism done. He's on his bloody Boris thing, smashing through the polystyrene blocks.
难道没有人说，“哦，天哪，这是对行政权力的篡夺，他不该这么做”吗？还是说他们已经被战争激进化到根本不在乎了？不，有很多人正是用这种方式、用这种语言在说这话。他在政治上具有极强的分裂性，而且当然，他是在中期选举前夕这么做的，随后共和党人在北方失去了大批国会席位，并输掉了一些关键职位——例如纽约州州长职位被一位反对解放政策的民主党人赢得。无论如何，他其实并没有真正把解放这件事落实到位。他在9月份的初步《解放奴隶宣言》中实际所说的是：如果这场战争在三个月后的1863年1月1日仍在进行，如果南方各州仍然假装它们在联邦之外，那么到那个时候，我将把那些仍然处于叛乱地区的被奴役人口视为自由人。这才是他真正——所以他没有做的是去解放——我的意思是，事实上，当这一天到来时，有数万名被奴役的人通过《解放奴隶宣言》直接获得了自由。但事实上，他所做的是宣布那些不在北军控制下的奴隶获得自由，而没有解放那些在北军控制下的奴隶。毕竟，当时仍然有四个蓄奴州在法律上允许蓄奴，但它们仍然留在联邦内——四个边界蓄奴州。那么杰斐逊·戴维斯（Jefferson Davis），邦联总统和他的同伙们，他们对此有何反应？
Are there not people who say, oh my God, what a usurpation of executive power, he shouldn't have done this? Or have they all become so radicalised by the war that they don't care anymore no there are loads of people saying exactly that in exactly in exactly that language he's politically very very divisive and of course he does it just before the midterm elections in which the republicans then lose a bunch of seats to the democrats in the north and lose some key the the new york governorship for example goes is won by a Democrat who's opposed to the emancipation policy. He's not really getting emancipation done though anyway. What he's actually saying in the September preliminary emancipation proclamation is, if this war is still going
我想象他们会欣喜若狂。他们认为这是人类战争长河中做出的最卑鄙的事情。这项解放政策所表现出的令人发指的绝望程度让他们感到震惊。这是他们终极的噩梦。这是他们一直以来对这个雅各宾式的黑色共和党人所恐惧的一切。
on on the 1st of January 1863 in three months' time, if the southern states are still pretending that they're outside of the union, then at that point, I will regard enslaved people in those areas still in rebellion as free. That's what he's actually... So what he's not doing is to free... I mean, there are, in fact, when it comes to it, some tens of thousands of enslaved people who are directly freed by the Emancipation Proclamation. But in fact, what he's doing is declaring free those slaves who are not in union control and not freeing those slaves who are in union control. And there are still, after all, at this point, four states where slavery is legal that are still in the union for border slave states. So Jefferson Davis, who is the president of the Confederacy and his pals, how do they react to this?
所以这大概让他们继续战斗的决心变得更加坚决了？是的，因为已经没有妥协的可能了。同样地，这也赋予了联邦——赋予那些为了联邦而坚信不疑地战斗的人们一种感觉，即他们正在参与一场我们或许可以称之为十字军东征的伟业。是的。因此，
I imagine with ecstatic joy. They regard it as the most dastardly thing ever done in the long annals of human warfare. But the levels of despicable desperation on display by this emancipation policy appalls them. It is their ultimate nightmare. It's everything they've always feared about this jacobinical black Republican Party.
这就为1863年做好了铺垫——1863年在许多方面可以说是整个战争的支点，我想我们应该在下一集中探讨这一点。汤姆，我以为你要问另一个问题，但实际上这是一个非常精彩的过渡，直接导向了本集的结尾。
And so presumably that makes their determination to fight on even more resolute. Yeah, because there can be no settlement. Likewise, it gives to the union, to those fighting from conviction for the union, a sense that they are engaged in what we might call a crusade. Yes. And so therefore it,
这非常好。我还要继续吗？这是在录制节目。我在夸你呢。哦，好吧。好吧。太客气了。好吧。
it sets up, sets us up for 1863, which in many ways is the kind of the, the fulcrum of the, the entire war, which I think we should look at in our next episode. Tom, I thought you were going to ask another question, but actually that was a beautiful segue into the end of the episode.
好吧，就着多米尼克所说的这个精彩结局，我们就此结束。再见。再见，再見，感谢收听《历史余音》（The Rest is History），若想收听独家节目、提前解锁内容、享受无广告收听并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目以及提前获得现场门票，本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。
It's very nice. Shall I carry on? This is for broadcast. I'm complimenting you. Oh, okay. All right. That's very kind. Okay.
非常好。我要继续吗？这是用于广播的。我在夸奖你。哦，好的。好的。太客气了。好的。
Well, on that, as Dominic described it, beautiful ending. We will end. Bye-bye. Bye-bye bye-bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad free listening and access to our chat community please sign up at rest is historyorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好吧，正如多米尼克所描述的那个精彩的结尾，我们就到这里。再见。再见，再见，感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest is History）。想要收听独家加更节目、提前解锁内容、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，向您揭示这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果您想要无广告收听、加更节目以及提前购买现场门票，本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。